bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce iront
parler sport l'émission ne surtout pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local au programme aujourd'hui
comme toujours des analyses techniques
des décryptages et surtout une dose de
bonne humeur pour m'accompagner nos
chroniqueurs sont avec nous sur ce
plateau à présentation de la a dream
team on commence à ma droite musique il
est encore présent dans cette émission
nous vient tout droit de la cité royale
de versailles
c'est un spécialiste rugby qui adore
batailler dans la mêlée mesdames et
messieurs notre gladiateurs pierre
chevallier nous fait l'honneur d'être
ici sur ce plateau formé bonheur en tout
salut les copains comment allez-vous
pierre en pleine forme pleine forêt que
ce serait qui revient cette
sympathie rayon soleil et on en prend
plein les mirettes c'est très agréable
apparemment vous êtes dom ou sur les
noms la saison a démarré la saison a
démarré donc pleine balle est il pour le
coup on peaufine un petit peu le
bronzage parfait on continue notre tour
de table musique il est journaliste chez
atb 78 est une véritable encyclopédie
sur le sport local et le sport italia il
va tout donner aujourd'hui comme
toujours notre italiana lovers le seul
l'unique l'incroyable virevoltant
grégory canale est avec nous bonjour
michael bonjour pierre bonjour à toutes
et à tous comment allez-vous vous aussi
vous pouvez signer votre bronzage on
peaufine son bronzage un petit coup de
blues parce que la saison arrive bientôt
à son terme on s'en rapproche petit à
petit donc ça veut dire que les
émissions si on part et sport vont
bientôt se terminer mais on voit on ne
parlait pas de malheur il reste quelques
numéros on va en profiter en tout cas on
a de quoi se consoler avec des baies
l'actualité sur le sport local et vous
gardez le masque parce que vous n'êtes
qu'à contacter
une nouvelle fois oui merci de ma vie
privée
on continue de l'autre côté à musique
c'est son deuxième six ans par les
sports aujourd'hui bien que novice elle
va vous surprendre elle est adepte de la
course à pied dans sa jeunesse à la fée
du tennis de table du badminton du
basket a également fait de la boxe le
marathon des sables dernièrement bref
c'est une sportive complète notre wonder
woman audrey le père l'eau fait
l'honneur de venir dans cette émission
ah bonjour merci pour l'invitation
bonjour à tous très contents d'être là
parce que la dernière fois c'était à tim
vision face à la team plateau donc très
bonne ambiance oui on a fait beaucoup
d'émissions en visio malheureusement pas
par les temps qui courent et là on en
plateau on est de retour en plateau et
ça fait du bien alors enfin voici notre
dernier chroniqueur une légende et sur
ce plateau musique il est charismatique
il est drôle il est de bonne humeur avec
ce beau temps qui règne dans les
yvelines depuis quelques jours la
légende le mythe l'incroyable coach
genlis ex-entraîneur de plaisir sera
avec nous pendant une heure
vous avez mis du temps à voir tourner
bonjour à tous à tout
comment va très bien
ça le soleil est radieux donc moi aussi
vous êtes en pleine forme c'est super
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission du tennis de table un tournoi
international de tennis de table
handisport était organisée la semaine
dernière du 5 au 8 mai pendant trois
jours au vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines un événement qui a
réuni des têtes d'affiché médaillé
olympique 250 à 300 athlètes et des
spectateurs dans les tribunes en tout
cas l'air central du vélodrome était à
bien remplie alors ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il ya des événements
hors cyclisme au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il ya eu de la
gymnastique en 2019 avec les
championnats de france il ya eu les
championnats de france de judo il ya eu
du handball avec l'équipe féminine du
paris 92 sur la centrale avec 5000
spectateurs autour la question sur cette
première thématique doit-on organisé
plus d'événements hors cyclisme au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
vous êtes unanime à l'argent pourquoi
pourquoi tout simplement parce que le
vélodrome il est fait non pas que pour
le vélo et que forcément en plus ça sans
critiquer la discipline parce que j'aime
bien le vélo mais en plus quand même
force de reconnaître que c'est pas le
vélo qui rapide le drôme a pas vraiment
très très peu de deux compétitions
s'étaient remplies voilà vraiment on ne
peut pas vraiment plein en 2015 lors des
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
des grandes occasions malheureusement
j'ai dû malheureusement il y a quand
même beaucoup de compétitions vélo au
vélodrome qui est on l'a déjà parlé
plusieurs fois sur le plateau qui
malheureusement ne font ne font pas
beaucoup de succès auprès des
spectateurs donc il y à d'autres
activités comme celle-là championnat
handisport à
tennis de table mais où il ya eu un peu
plus de un peu de monde et des
concessions fait venir du monde
d'adultes ça qui est prévu pour ça on
peut être que que quotas et et
encourager ce genre de de compétition
audrey qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors vous avez fait d'utiliser talent
vous dans ce match reste j'en ai
beaucoup fait je sais ce que c'est comme
comme territoire oui donc le vélo de
route nationale de 50 ans n'y est un
lieu emblématique depuis à 2014 je pense
que c'est un lieu qui est évidemment
liée pour le sport c'est un lien social
mais c'est aussi un lieu dans lequel on
peut accueillir différents événements
comme la musique comme les événements
comme les meetings les séminaires et je
me souviens très bien qui est là c'est
aussi un endroit pour accueillir un
centre de vaccination donc c'est un lieu
qui est extrêmement propice à aux liens
sociaux et puis effectivement je
souhaiterais effectivement saluer notre
cher et merveilleux arnaud courtier qui
est le spécialiste des zizou pour 2024
donc sur le territoire de sa surdité
oui que je que je connais régulièrement
parce qu'on court ensemble et j'essaie
de le suivre à la course à pied d'accord
qui est devant du coup c'est lui + cause
d'accords fait soleil hier qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous connaissez mon amour
inconsidéré pour le vélo confiture
commencer par disant bon un vélodrome
qui ne sert pas qu'aux vélo bon mois sur
moi ça me fait voilà ça me fait plaisir
c'est patricia finalement de la
parenthèse non non c'est pas triste
parce que on n'a pas non plus des ans un
grand nombre d'enceintes sportives en
france on en a plus depuis la fin la fin
du 21e siècle la fin du xxème siècle
bardon et depuis 98 tout on a eu on a eu
des finalement un élan sportif qui fait
que le sport se met à faire recette donc
allez stade de sport collectif ouvert
foot rugby et puis à tous les autres
sports qui se sont fait une place depuis
depuis barcelone par exemple avec le
handball donc des enceintes fermées des
gymnases
on
a un déficit de culture sportive en
france chez des jeunes chez les enfants
à l'école ça on en parle suffisamment
ici donc la multiplication des antennes
sportive est une bonne chose maintenant
qu'elle serve à d'autres choses c'est
aussi des carrefour de rencontres
sociaux des carrefours sociaux de
rencontre où dragon sociale etc c'est
réunir beaucoup de beaucoup de personnes
des spectateurs des familles dans des
enceintes si on prend là l'exemple du
vélodrome il ya jean l'a rappelé assez
peu de assez peu d'événements qui font
recette sur le vélo on a on a beaucoup
parlé sur ce plateau d'autres événements
je me souviens aussi de la moto il y
avait eu un il y avait il ya vu la moto
il y avait des éléments extrêmement
festif où on avait des rigoles et a
étudié à étudier ce ces phénomènes et
ces événements là je pense que tout
tourne toute occasion qui est donnée de
se retrouver surtout après la après deux
ans si part si particulier à ne pas se
voir à ne pas se réunir et là en
l'occurrence à donner de la visibilité à
des sports qui en manquent type le
handisport au tennis de table par
exemple c'est une excellente chose on
s'adresse pas forcément exactement au
même public mais en tous les cas on
donne rendez vous aux spectateurs
téléspectateurs aussi parce qu'il ya ça
aussi on parlerait on parlerait des
droits télé on dirait peut-être la même
chose il ya beaucoup de sport qui monte
d'un qui ont un déficit de visibilité la
diversifier les activités et les sports
dans une enceinte comme le vélodrome
c'est une très bonne chose grégory
plaisir à voir des événements au
vélodrome surtout après cette période où
il a été plutôt fermé puisque il ya été
ouvert un centre de vaccination donc on
a envie de revoir à des événements
sportifs là c'est la preuve que d'autres
événements peuvent se tenir en plus on
ne parle pas de n'importe quel événement
alors c'était que la deuxième édition de
cet open français il y en avait eu un
premier à voisins le bretonneux la passe
sur un open a plus grande ampleur 16 à
20 table l'idée c'est d'en faire quand
même un tournoi qualificatif pour les
jeux paralympiques en plus il y avait
des médailles et paralympiques il y
avait la crème mondiale du tennis de
table handisport et on a vu sur d'autres
sports que le vélodrome pouvait faire
ses preuves en termes d'enceinte il ya
eu des matchs de handball paris 92 qui
s'appelait le issy paris hand à l'époque
qui avait accueilli brest pour un
championnat pour le match de championnat
les vipers aussi de christophe sand
également l'équipe norvégienne sur la
coupe d'europe et on a vu que sur ces
formules là est bien le public est au
rendez vous on était à guichets fermés à
sac à chaque fois parce qu'on est sur
une enceinte de 5000 places d'ailleurs
on est sur une capacité une arena parmi
les principales en ile de france et donc
on a envie de voir d'autres événements
sportifs mais aussi audrey le rappeler
musicaux aussi ça peut être des
événements musicaux on a eu des
événements dédiés au dubstep à l'électro
qui ont aussi attiré leur foule donc
il ya eu là du têtu partie donc cet
événement festif autour de la moto donc
je pense que oui on a envie de voir ce
genre d'événement est de toute façon on
les aura là il ya le championnat du
monde de cyclisme sur piste qui revient
et on espère revoir une enceinte pleine
il ya forcément les jeux olympiques qui
vont arriver il y aura notamment de
l'isq là normalement pour les jeux
olympiques ça devrait normalement
normalement ça devrait être plein et en
plus on aura pas du vélo de piste on
aura aussi les scream du pentathlon
moderne donc d'autres épreuves également
rapidement les sports insolites aussi
qui sont présents au vélodrome il va
avoir notamment en championnat de
crossfit aussi bientôt au match au
vélodrome est ce que c'est aussi une
piste pour le vélodrome à explorer des
sports un peu insolite qui sortent de
l'ordinaire que pas tout le monde
connaît forcément
parce qu'il faut multiplier les
discipline tels ça fait par les
disciplines comme le crossfit on en
parle beaucoup mais on n'en voit pas
beaucoup on aime parler de revanche
c'est d'actualité c'est peu la
discipline à la mode mais on n'en voit
pas beaucoup donc c'est une manière
comme une autre de parler de cette
discipline et de la montrer à ouvrir aux
spectateurs
dansaient dans ses axes là la logique
économique une oie une enceinte comme
celle là il faut la rentabiliser il ya
eu des investissements assez assez lourd
va c'est lourd départ pour la
construction l'exploitation elle exige
justement une diversification pour
pouvoir justement rentabiliser
l'opération et quand on reste dans le
sport en général on est sur ce plateau à
parler de sport c'est une c'est une
bonne occasion de rentabiliser
l'investissement de départ donc quoi
qu'il arrive il faut le remplir oui
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission jean nous allons
parler des jeux olympiques de 2024 on a
l'impression que ça se précise dans les
yvelines nous parlerons également de the
body building en illinois se passionne
pour ce sport mais avant de parler de
ces thèmes on va parler football et de
versailles
[Applaudissements]
on continue donc par du football est une
très bonne nouvelle pour le sport
évinois je n'en dis pas plus je vous
laisse se développer grigoris c'est
votre envolée du jour une de plus de
bonnes nouvelles j'aimerais souligner
que dans si on parlait spa on est quand
même chanceux on a vécu l'an passé une
magnifique saison au niveau des
résultats la troisième place au vendée
globe de louis burton l'ascension
fulgurante également et d'arthur hinder
tenait sa s'est poursuivie sur la fin
d'année également en 2021 est à présent
quelle année 2022 quel début d'année
2022 grâce à notre équipe mascotte
devenu star même dans la france entière
le football-club de versailles grâce à
sa victoire contre saint malo le 30
avril dernier conjugués aux faux pas de
son rival chartres face à caen l'équipe
de la cité royale a validé son accession
dans le championnat de national c'est le
troisième échelon du football français
au dessus il n'ya que la ligue 2 et la
ligue 1 7 noté vient couronner une
saison non pas juste satisfaisante non
pas juste réussi mais exceptionnelle
il y à il y avait déjà eu plutôt la
coupe de france et cette accession
historique en demis finales de la
compétition contre nice en éliminant
notamment toulouse dans ce parcours ce
qui a permis une grande exposition
médiatique du club yves hinant souvient
forcément de cette vidéo à mourir de
rire sur les sopranos 1 qui avait fait
une thématique autour des ultras
versaillais et le rêve se poursuit
aujourd'hui avec cette promotion en
national c'est l'occasion pour moi pour
nous est d'adresser quelques
félicitations bravo et merci aux joueurs
qui n'ont pas flanché la bande à tu
rends de jeu vignal berkak a su jouer
sur les deux tableaux la coupe de france
ayant même servi de catalyseur et depuis
la fin de l'aventuré voici le bilan en
championnat 6 victoires deux matches
nuls et aucune défaite le fc versailles
est toujours bon leader de nationale 2
avec 7 points d'avancé sur la réserve de
lorient qui on le rappelle ne peut pas
monter dans le championnat national et
12 points sur chartres bravo également à
l'entraîneur youssef qui bique est
parvenu à construire un groupe
victorieux et gardiez garder les siens
mobiliser la tâche n'était pas facile
avec un effectif en grande partie
renouvelé l'été dernier c'est une juste
récompense pour le travail accompli
depuis sa prise de fonction en 2014 elle
est montée progressive du club de la
cité royale aujourd'hui versailles est
aussi une ville de football c'est enfin
un pari réussi pour la direction du club
les nouveaux investisseurs et du groupe
citi le directeur général jean-luc
arribart beaucoup d'argent a été
injectée certes mais les moyens ont
finalement est à la hauteur des
ambitions avec des objectifs atteints
dès la première année et je voulais
enfin adressé des remerciements aux
supporters on les oublie pas mitchell
ils ont été fidèles au football club de
versailles supporters ils ont été ils
ont été de tous les déplacements cette
saison et je pense que l'on gardera tous
les deux dans un coin de nos têtes se
souvenir de ce voyage à leurs côtés à
périgueux c'était pour le quart de
finale de coupe de france face à
bergerac blanc terre donc ça a été très
mouvementée on le voit est en tout cas
on les remercie aussi pour pour leur
accueil à ce moment là j'ai envie de
vous dire que la fête sera belle le
samedi 14 mai pour le premier match à
domicile depuis la bonne nouvelle de
cette accession en nationale 1 match à
18h contre pas bhl plabennec au stade
montbron et j'ai une super j'espère que
ce sera ce sera pas une dernière dans
l'écrin yvelines à il noah car oui il ya
encore des dossiers à régler qui j'en
suis sûr vont faire grincer quelques
dents en plateau carpediem disait aura
ce que ion le moment présent sans se
soucier du lendemain tout du moins pour
l'instant
votre avis sur cette envolée peu de mal
sur la fin un petit peu de mal mais bon
c'est l'émotion
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
cette envolée pierre peut-être ensuite
audrey à moi c'est sûr le évidemment on
suit nos voisins nos voisins du ballon
avec avec grande attention au rugby à
versailles
et on a beaucoup discuté récemment à la
fois pour continuer à faire connaissance
puisqu'on me partage on partage le même
stade apport chaudfontaine les
installations de la ville de versailles
donc on a beaucoup échangé sur le sur
les déjà sur la saison en cours et
puisqu'on est on est tous les deux sur
nos deux sports sur des montées et
démontées potentiel c'est acquis pour le
football c'est en cours pour le rugby et
puis sur la vision la vision qu'on a si
les objectifs si nos deux objectifs
respectifs sont atteints et force est de
constater que le le projet de duos et
versailles depuis le milieu de l'année
2021 est désormais bien mûres
sportivement déjà ils n'ont pas brûler
les étapes ils ont ils sont allés y sont
allés au bout montée acquise il ya un
titre de champion un titre honorifique
de champion de nationale 2 mais avec une
saison très très bien mené beaucoup de
matches nuls pas mal de victoires est
assez peu de défaites donc finalement il
faut savoir ne pas perdre avec les mains
avec les matches nuls et 2 défaites avec
la coupe 2 et pour la suite on sait on
sait qu'il ya un certain nombre de
questions pour l'instant sans réponse
définitive sur la saison prochaine on va
parler du stade évidemment ce qu'on peut
dire là ce stade c'est dans ce qu'ils
nous disent qu'ils partagent avec nous
déjà ils sont ils sont sur une île sont
sur une donnée de finir la saison les
informations officielles actuellement
sont sur la fin de la saison ils gèrent
leur fin de saison le titre et la montée
vers la saison prochaine victoire pour
sur la montée pour le titre et pour le
pour la suite et notamment sur cette
question de stade et d'organisation des
futurs matches de national pour
versailles il ya plusieurs options à
l'étude on va en parler ce qui est la
décision n'est pas prise ce qu'on va
évoquer notamment à saint gratien c'est
une des options qui est évoqué et pas
forcément encore tranché donc tout ça
pour dire on a on a on a
adoré suivre suivre le trajet de de nos
cousins cousin ballon et nos copains nos
copains à côté notamment à travers les
réseaux sociaux on s'est beaucoup
répondu il ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup
de sportivité il ya beaucoup d'amitié il
ya beaucoup de convivialité entre les
deux sports contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait croire au départ et ce qui est
la cerise sur le gâteau est dixit d'ici
de françois de mazières maire de
versailles qu'on a vu vendredi à bourges
fontaine c'est que versailles s'installe
définitivement non seulement comme une
ville de culture et d'histoire mais
aussi comme une ville sportive et là
pour le coup c'est reconnu au niveau
départemental régional et nature et ce
qui change un peu à versailles ce
n'était pas forcément le cas il ya
quelques années évidemment évidemment de
jeu souvient à des temps que les moins
de vingt ans ne peuvent pas connaître
quand nous ont joué devant devant une
vingtaine de spectateurs à bourges
fontaine c'est vrai que la balle à
dimanche dernier il y avait il y avait
hier je parle même pas des influences
pour le foot qui ont été votées colossal
et au rugby on a on était autour de 900
personnes à porsche l'antenne dimanche
dernier donc c'est de toute façon une
émulation saine et autour du sport à
versailles audrey qu'est ce que vous en
pensez du coup de cette envolée grégory
de cette montée à versaillaise en 3e
division a déjà c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle je pense que déjà on ils ont
fait une belle saison moi je suis assez
contente qu'un retournement de situation
on n'aurait jamais imaginé une misé sur
ce type d' équipe aujourd'hui
effectivement ce que je te rejoins
complètement la versailles donne une
autre couleur en fait évidemment sur la
culture mais sur le sport et la cohésion
d'équipé je suis assez content de
pouvoir suivre entre guillemets un
nouveau club et d'avoir fait cette
cohésion en fait au niveau de versailles
et des autres clubs donc que genre de
choix de miser sur eux et encore plus et
soutenir leur donner peut-être plus de
sponsors plus d'équipements de l'eau de
qualité et pour un peu les usa coach et
moi donc tant qu'à faire
justement ce problème peut-être qu'ils
vont partir un peu plus loin on ne sait
pas encore alors jean cette envolée du
coût que vous en pensez vous de
versailles c'est quand même quand même
l'équipe qu'on n'attendait pas forcément
on espérer une montée en début de saison
et finalement si une année dominée de la
tête et des épaules tous engagés avec
superbe parcours qu'on lui connaît un
groupe de phrases aller jusqu'à la
finale demi finale et demi-finale par
excusez moi merci je le voyais moins
final voilà l'aude en demi-finale contre
une excellente contre aunis y perdre 2-0
contre nice est donc
on ne prendre que 4 4 compte tenu de
leur parcours de les féliciter ensuite
bon la montée c'est comme l'a dit pierre
c'est une une étape par rapport à
vraiment leur objectif qui est vraiment
de monter dans l'élite
donc ils prennent les choses dans
l'ordre ce qui est très très bien après
on sait que plus on monte dans n'importe
quel sport plus on monte plus c'est
difficile et puis le niveau et demande
demande de plus en plus de perfection et
on le sait tous les d'argent également
de sponsors genre et d'argent alors le
milieu mon argent je pense que il ya
peut-être certainement ce qu'il faut
maintenant après il ya tout le côté
sportif et le côté résultats à mettre
autour donc là c'est une autre affaire
la question sur cette thématique est ce
que versailles peut faire partie du
paysage footballistique français
oui ou non oui pour voudrez difficile
pour vous grégory non pour vous jean et
oui pour vous pierrât du couvent argent
je vous donne la parole et pierre ou le
voulu répondre un petit duel
judiciaire j'aime bien
jamie chez la moitié non mais j'ai dit
non pourquoi parce que effectivement
versailles football grande saison coupe
de france donc il était sous les
projecteurs parce qu'ils ont fait leur
leur parcours à coup de phrases après il
ne faut pas oublier même si c'est la
troisième division française il ne
montre qu'un nationale et quelques mois
je pourrais je regarde les
normal émissions tv sur le football
qu'il peut y avoir la maison
on ne parle que de la ligue 1 peut en
ligue 2 mais on parle jamais national
jamais jamais jamais jamais donc
versailles cette saison ils sont connus
par rapport à leur parcours en coupe de
france mais demain ils vont retomber un
petit peu dans l'anonymat nationale je
parle puisque là on dit du paysage
français footballistique pour moi non
parce qu'ils vont retomber
malheureusement ce qui n'est pas
attention niveau national c'est pas non
plus on l'a répété c'est le troisième le
troisième niveau au football mais ça ne
suffira pas pour faire partie vraiment
du paysage français footballistique
pierre vous n'avez pas précisé de deux
facteurs tonnes de dattes et de deadline
donc moi mon propose c'est de dire que
oui ils peuvent faire partie de l'élite
au-delà de l'aspect chauvin et
versailles et sur ceux sur ce trajet que
tout le monde a salué sur la saison 2021
2022 c'est que le projet global dixit
les acteurs majeurs donc jean luc et
jean luc arribart en tête et ses deux
présidents et ses deux présidences et la
montée au moins les deux je sais pas si
je suis pas sûr que l'objectif
ligue 1 soit soit soit assumée mais au
moins l'avis de donc à la question
peut-il faire partie du paysage
footballistique français oui s'il accède
en ligue 2 d'accord avec jean nationale
on a une exposition médiatique sur
plutôt que chez les confrères
d'eurosport là dessus avec des matches
le soir là aussi on n'en parle pas parce
que sadc il ya des contraintes
techniques pour le go pour
l'organisation des matches mais avec
l'objectif ligue 2 et qui semble qu'ils
semblent atteignables après après 7,7
ces choses dans l'ordre et après à vous
de ce planning respecté de monde et
d'abord nationales après il va falloir y
figurer il va falloir il va falloir
scorer et performer en national et puis
pour voir pour voir la porte de la porte
de la ligue 2 ça ne devrait pas se faire
en une saison à mon avis même si les
investisseurs sont là même si les
sponsors vont arriver même si d'autres
d'autres joueurs et donc peut-être des
têtes d'affiché des idées et des grands
noms vont arriver et vont arriver à
versailles
j'associerai simplement aussi maintenant
cet espace est à ce projet
l'aspect nouveauté que qu'audrey rappelé
sur la ville de versailles en dix ans et
que vous rappeliez aussi sanaa ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas
le sport à versailles à la hauteur du
château ou de la culture sauf que là
cette année avec l'exposition on a eu en
coupe de france et est en championnat et
on a placé versailles qui est un nom
connu qui est une ville connue sur la
sur la carte de géographie sportives
françaises on est encore certes encore
loin de lyon de paris donnant sans coupe
de france par exemple mais par exemple
vous prenez en ligue 2 bordeaux qui
hélas était importe de la descente en
ligue 2 on ne rappelle pas le palmarès
et les grandes heures de bordeaux mais
voilà c'est une ville connue qui a eu
ses heures de gloire voilà qui a priori
va descendre en ligue 2 versailles peut
s'installer dans le paysage avec ce
projet à quelques années de montée en
dit peut-être qu'on verra des versailles
bordeaux en dans un an peut-être
bishop avait en 2002 ouai s'ils
remontent pas alors entre équipes qui
vous a convaincu jean pierre
je suis d'accord parce qu on dit un
facteur temps est important on dit que
la timone alors est ce qui est important
de dire c'est que ma robe ne s'est pas
construit en un jour je pense
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui voilà ils
sortent du lot je pense qu'il faut
effectivement les soutenir et les
accompagner
alors évidemment dans deux ans peut-être
qu'on les verra un peu plus sur le
terrain j'ai envie de dire aussi c'est
aussi une bonne on m'a dit à une belle
référence aussi aux grandes lans diab
attention les petits arrivent pas se
laisser battre sur leurs acquis donc
versailles oui dans deux ans trois ans
et je suis dans l'optique de les
soutenir le plus longtemps possible
régulièrement
j'étais partagé je pense que c'est
possible dans un laps de temps après qui
restera à définir j'ai envie de vous
dire le plus dur maintenant est à venir
le plus dur est à venir parce que la
montée en national est acquise
maintenant de passer cet échelon
supplémentaire en ligue 2 quand on sait
que dans l'élite on est en train de
réduire aussi le nombre de participants
au championnat forcément au nombre des
montées ça va aussi se réduire donc ça
sera beaucoup plus difficile pour le
club versailles est donc on va voir ce
qui va se passer la saison prochaine et
ce qu'ils vont retenir les joueurs qui
aussi participé à cette épopée qui vont
être forcément difficiles à retenir on
parle de mal durant devinez qui a
approché par un club de ligue 2 c'est
nîmes donc ça c'est difficile déjà de
retenir les joueurs on va voir quel
effectif aura youssef chibi je l'espère
s'il reste à sa disposition j'anticipe
déjà sur le débat d'après mais moi je
pense qu'il ya des outils zing
aujourd'hui dans cette émission il ya
des avantages pour versailles là il ya
des dossiers à régler le stade le stade
aussi qu'il sera un dossier réglé ce que
versailles jours encore dans son antre
de montbron la saison prochaine et ce
qu'elle sera obligé cette équipe
versaillaise est d'aller jouer ailleurs
à cause des normes qui exige cette
nature est ressassé un dossier qui reste
à régler et alors moi je pense qu'il ya
un avantage pour pour versailles c'est
aussi la marque versailles ces terres
que au niveau mondial versailles ça
parle à tout le monde alors ça parle
pour le château bien évidemment mais je
pense que pour s'installer aussi dans le
paysage il faut aussi une image
marketing une image on va dire sur sur
les réseaux sociaux et je pense que ça
c'est un vrai avantage pour cent c'est
que versailles parle plus que clabecq
par exemple que j'essaie de dire avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour fait la
bnf oui oui mais bien sûr au niveau
mondial versailles ça parle à tout le
monde alors justement on va on va
enchaîner par ce stade mot bord on ne
sait pas encore s'ils allaient verser
vont pouvoir s'installer dans ce stade
en bout rond la saison prochaine on
parle de sannois saint gratien qu'est ce
que vous en pensez alors c'est un stade
le stade des sports michel hidalgo de
saint gratien il est situé à 30
kilomètres de la préfecture des yvelines
donc à une centaine de mètres du stade
mais bon qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
ce choix de saint gratien gens
pas grand chose mais non c'est pas ça
c'est pour moi honnêtement ça
parce qu'il ya toujours cette
problématique avec l'éclairage le savons
en gros on a beau ne pas avoir voilà
d'éclairage depuis la chambre du roi
soleil pour moi un club qui nous est là
dans sa ville
on parle de l'image justement et du
nombre versailles et si vraiment ils
veulent ils veulent figurer comme vous
le dites le paysage footballistique
français c'est un petit grain de sable
dans le rouage le fait d'aller jouer
ailleurs qu'à versailles et en plus à
sannois saint gratien qui est quand même
plus on va vous trouver mais c'est même
pas vrai c'est qu'un 30 km même pour les
supporters j'irai pas que ce déplacement
de l'image j'avais quasiment go on est
on est plus à la maison et justement
puisqu'on à en parler beaucoup devaient
parler beaucoup l'étiquette est l'image
versailles qui est mondialement connue
bella on la perd un peu quand même ça
c'est de sortie jasserie pour une année
non seulement pour l'instant
audrey c'est temporaire et c'est comme
une équipe savoir être souple et
flexible effectivement l'émotion mais
sachant que c'est un an c'est là une
fois s'entraîner c'est effectivement
c'est tranquille massé pas à côté mais
c'est là effectivement on va connaître
un petit peu leur leur leur flexibilité
et leur manière aussi de fonctionner
c'est pas dans dix ans dans un an dans
tête un meilleur parc des sports
d'entraînement nantes est aussi des
sponsors un peu plus fort et au
contraire versa il se développe
s'inscrit aussi dans différents
territoires pour se rencontrer parler de
marketing et de communication c'est pas
au sein avis et dans les différentes
villes se rencontrer c'est changer je
pensais aussi à une bonne un bon début
et mais sportivement sportivement là
pour les joueurs c'est et n'ont pas
besoin de ça parce qu'ils niveau il
monta nationale et d'eau qu'ils ont
besoin de continuer sur leur élan
sportif et sportivement ils y sont ils
sont déracinés et c'est important alors
une flexibilité certes mais c'est quand
même un petit grain de sable est ce que
ça les perturbe vraiment les joueurs
finalement la wii par we are de ma vie
des gens ah oui oui on a des gens et moi
avons des exemples dans le rugby on peut
parler par exemple du stade français
paris qui était et qui a été assez
nomades pendant quelques années
c'est l'expression jouer à domicile
jouer à la maison ça un vrai sens aux
sports c'est un vrai cependant en
repères en praticité bien sûr il s'agit
pas de dire que forcément tous les
joueurs versailles et de l'effectif
versailles et habite versailles ou ou
très proches parce qu'il y en a sûrement
qui avec habite à paris ou ailleurs mais
mais en tout cas c'est un c'est un côté
un côté pratique pratique et rassurant
mais ce qu'il faut dire de toute façon
ces cas-là de source très proche du
dossier c'est que cette cette option
saint gratien elle est une des options
qui est actuellement étudié la
principale que
c'est bien mon boxer donc cesser ses
obsessions numéro une en cas d'échec oui
c'est simplement pour entrer en cas
d'échec de mont boron mais il ya eu
quand même dernièrement grâce à cette
exposition médiatique aux trajets en
coupe de france à la montée en national
des avancées dans les négociations avec
l'architecte des bâtiments de france
puisque effectivement il ne faut pas
être dans un halo de lumière ne peut pas
être dans un rayon de 5 km autour du
château de versailles et la chambre la
chambre de louis
mais ceci étant dit des avancées ont été
ont été trouvés et notamment avec des
solutions palliatives peut-être
temporaire mais qui qui qui sont à la
limite maximum en termes de hauteur des
mâts d'éclairage puisque les matches se
jouent majoritairement fin de journée
donc en plein hiver c'est en nocturne
donc il faut éclairer et c'est une c'est
une des pistes qui a quand même le plus
avancé qui vous l'avez vous l'avez
rappelé vous avez raison n'est pas
encore validé à 100% donc il faut des
plans b et c'est là où le c'est là où
saint gratien est sorti du chapeau avec
le stade michel hidalgo mais c'est une
des pistes qui était étudie actuellement
et qui est qui est justement largement
débattu en interne comme en externe
parce qu'effectivement ça ça a des
conséquences alors avant de passer à la
prochaine thématique sur versa je vous
propose de regarder ce logo il va
apparaître à l'écran versailles football
club c'est un nouveau logo justement
pour entrer dans une nouvelle ère qu'est
ce que vous en pensez audrey
qui traîne
le marketing versailles et gémit
hambourg je pense que c'est assez clair
en termes de en termes de couleurs en
termes de chromie ça c'est assez dire
elle c'est plutôt sympathique ça vous
plaît ça va jean jamais nouvelles idées
ouais mais le le soleil les armes henry
marshall fund le club s'est donc grégory
et sympathique oui c'est vrai qu'on est
dans une un peu une standardisation des
logos de foot parce que moi ça me fait
penser un peu même si c'est pas les
mêmes couleurs au logo de paris et celle
ci aussi oui c'est vrai mais legault du
mariage et voilà qui a mis en gros
l'identité paris et en tout petit en
dessous saint-germain bon là c'est
football club après on garde le 118
disparaît je crois le 78 disparus on
garde quand même un symbole c'est le
soleil et le roi soleil qui était déjà
présent sur sur l'ancien logo non on va
dans cette voie que souhaite prendre
versailles celle d'une
professionnalisation on va dire petit à
pied ce logo va dans ce sens la pierre
moi j'aime me j'aime bien j'aime bien le
parti pris et je suis très surpris par
le côté assumé 2d des signes versailles
et fleur de lys roi soleil dans un logo
de football d'une équipe de football
honnêtement je n'aurais pas parié dessus
si je prends le logo le logo du rcv on a
les fleurs de lys on a peur on n'a pas
le roi soleil c'est peut-être un petit
peu partie de l'aventuré en coupe de ce
côté il ce cliché qui a été bien sûr et
c'est ce côté totalement assumé que je
trouve à la fois très audacieux et pour
le coup assez
surprenant et moi ça me ravit et samarra
ville justement qu'on assume les
standards peut-être même parfois les
clichés on vous avait parlé des débats
de tron les supporters les ultras
versailles et d'aller jusqu'au bout du
jusqu'au bout de la démarche je trouve
ça je trouve ça très bien sûr la
question c'est est ce que ce sera fait
fc ou lcv toujours est ce que sera
versailles football club football club
vert ils qui sera garde
la communication c'est c'est lui qui
nous en dira un peu plus là-dessus alors
on continue à parler de versailles plus
particulièrement de l'entraîneur youssef
chibi l'un des hommes forts de cette
saison versaillaise il est au club de
versailles depuis la saison 2014 il a
propulsé le club en nationale 2 puis en
national il a connu de beaux parcours en
coupe de france et notamment cette demi
finale face à nice il a 40 ans est-ce
qu'il doit rester au club certaines
rumeurs évoquent un possible
remplacement avec le statut de
versailles qui progresse qu'est ce que
vous en pensez doit-il rester à
versailles la saison prochaine oui ou
non oui partagé pour vous genre pourquoi
vous donner la parole aux gens et
ensuite on laissera les autres
chroniqueurs débattre partager partager
tout simplement parce que depuis 2014 ça
fait huit ans 8 8 saisons huit saisons
avec des résultats certes de monter mais
huit saisons c'est que j'ai remonté même
il est parti de dh sur des largeurs donc
donc avec des résultats on va dire des
résultats mais ça fait quand même huit
saisons et huit saisons avec le même
entraîneur le le discours là les
manières
de faire de s'entraîner les halls et les
approches sur les matchs les faits tout
ce que tout ce qui peut mettre à
disposition de ses joueurs mais il n'y a
pas de secret ça s'use ça s'use de huit
saisons c'est beaucoup alors c'est sûr
que sur les langues on va dire pourquoi
on va on va pas le 5 / et il vient de
faire monter le club en national pour
moi ce serait pas le sanctionner ce
serait peut-être avec un discours tout
dépend aussi de ce que veut le club est
ce que le club veut justement un nouveau
discours un nouvel élan où est ce qu'ils
veulent continuer sur sept et lala qui
pour l'instant est
pppp comptable puisque il est il a des
résultats et ils montrent la nationale
donc il faudrait il faut ré pour moi
avoir la vie mais les dirigeants savoir
exactement ce qu'ils veulent faire et
des joueurs aussi est ce que les joueurs
s'y d'abord le groupe si le groupe e
reste 6e ils sont pas usées du discours
de l'entraîneur parce que tout ça à ce
niveau là on peut plus permettre de
faire entre guillemets l'amateurisme
même si nationale 2 s'était pas
l'amateurisme mais là ça fait huit
saisons donc je pense quand même que il
faudrait avoir plus d'éléments et savoir
si lui aussi veut rester peut-être que
lui se sent aussi usé parce que c'est
c'est tout le monde sait l'entraîneur ce
sont les joueurs les dirigeants il ya
une usure qui s'installe et pour moi
huit saisons c'est beaucoup
pour pouvoir continuer en plus sur une
échelle qui va être un gros gros gros
challenge à nationale audrey on ne
change pas une équipe qui gagne bonjour
je suis toujours dans cette positivité
mais c'est vrai que quelle est
l'ambition en filmant des équipes
quelles ambitions
et des joueurs apprennent youssef c'est
quand même un entraîneur qui a 40 ans et
dans une carrière hockey huit saisons
c'est quand même beaucoup mais
aujourd'hui un sportif on connaît des
hauts et des bas c'est justement là où
c'est intéressant de pouvoir dire les
points d'amélioration là où
effectivement ça marche bien comment
est-ce qu'on peut peut-être réajuster
une équipe la faire évoluer en
compétences et comment effectivement
bien l'accompagner 40 ans est
extrêmement jeune moi je suis dans le
parti pris de de le supporter et ça
commence bien ça continue effectivement
il ya des belles réflexions je suis
d'accord steve manqué d'ambition c'est
important de le rappeler mais je suis
partie prenante de soutenir et d'aller
le plus loin possible en tout cas avec
un jeune entraîneur d'agri je pense que
ce serait une juste récompense justement
pour le travail accompli depuis 2014 il
ya eu trois montées versailles était en
division d'honneur donc l'actuel
régionale 1 caen youssef chebbi est
arrivé à la tête du club il a donc
obtenu trois montées là sur une saison
il a prouvé que avec pas énormément de
moyens avec les moyens d'un club qui
était aux ambitions de versailles avant
il savait faire du bon travail avec plus
de moyens il a réussi aussi à faire du
bon travail je vous le disais tout à
l'heure avec un effectif qui a quand
même été renouvelée en grande partie
cette saison il ya plus de la moitié de
nouveaux joueurs qui sont qui sont
arrivés il ya eu aussi deux nouveaux
arrivés de nouvelles arrivées à
l'intersaison donc il a réussi à
intégrer ces renforts il a réussi à
construire une cohésion med équipe parce
que moi c'est ce qui m'a marqué aussi
sur cette saison c'est la force de ce
groupe qui a su est bien allé jusqu'en
demi finale de cette coupe de france
youssef chebbi y est forcément pour
quelque chose il de même pour beaucoup
et pour moi ce serait une juste
récompense au moins de le garder pour la
saison prochaine et on va voir on lui
laisse sa chance sur sur championnat
national ici ça se passe pas bien si la
baryte route pour lui à ce moment là aux
dirigeants de prendre leur décision
pierre je souhaite qu'il reste pour deux
raisons la maîtrise et le critère
sportif la maîtrise moi j'ai gelé on l'a
souvent évoquée sur ce plateau là et
j'ai dit j'ai été assez eu assez épaté
par par cette capacité qui l'avait amené
son groupe comme le comme le rappelait
greg et surtout à absorber la pression
quasiment pour son groupe notamment avec
ce trajet en phase finale en phase
finale de la coupe de france allait
jusqu'en jusqu'en jusqu'en demi-finales
se prendre le scalp de deux clubs de
ligue 1 et de ligue 2 c'est pas c'est
pas donné à n'importe quel type
d'entraîneur et à n'importe quel type de
groupe donc pour cette maîtrise et pour
la continuité je suis de l'avis de greg
je souhaiterais banque il qu'il reste
qu'ils restent derrière qu'il reste au
moins au moins cette saison là et parce
que c'est la nationale alors il ya un
gap ans il ya sûrement comme dans tous
les sports un gros gap entre la
nationale 2 et nationale ça sera pas les
mêmes équipes sera pas les mêmes
affiches ne sera pas les mêmes
expériences d'equipe ça sera pas les
mêmes groupes mais justement sur sur cet
esprit de groupe qu'il a su insuffler
pendant toutes ces saisons à versailles
la continuité me semble être une bonne
chose le critère sportif après derrière
et j'avais marqué j'avais marqué
toulouse parce que finalement certes
c'est un c'était un quart de finale
c'est un 8e de finale 8e de finale de
coupe de france donc c'est un coup mais
il a quand même il a quand même
accrochés et battu le premier de ligue 2
qui remonte en ligue 1 donc largement
les biarrots qu'il faut être il faut
être capable évidemment de faire ce type
de prestations toutes les semaines à
chaque match là on est en coupe de
france c'est particulier c'est un esprit
particulier et les l'ambiance
particulière mais quand même il il a
réussi à résister face à nice en demi en
huitièmes à toulouse
il
a existé face il ya une équipe de nice
qui avait battu marseille et nice et
paris sa des paris
d'autant gros poursuit que c'est notre
la
partie et je pense qu'il est capable
justement est capable d'exister en
national mais est-ce qu'au bout d'un
moment les dirigeants ont pas se dire on
veut un nom peut-être parce que youssef
chebbi oui c'est faire un nom peut-elle
cette année mais ce qu'on ne veut pas un
nom
par exemple qui est question marché où
outre sur un big john a par exemple
envoyé un col a aussi qui est versée qui
a proposé qui a dit pourquoi pas moi
j'ai jamais dit plus haut je veux bien
venir entraîner vers celles ci sont en
ligue 2 par exemple
pourquoi pas
alors je sais que ça vous parle pas
beaucoup d'avenir n'ont été l'un des
dirigeants de la mls
non mais lol moi je vous remet pas du
tout en cause de ses capacités et et les
entraîneurs ont surgi d'un versailles
j'essaie de le faire seuls à vouloir un
nom un peu plus prestigieux seul jean
luc arribart seul l'argent car les dares
ça ne choquerait pas si les dirigeants
le remercier pour son travail qui est
qu'un énorme trois montées en mettant
les formes
en y mettant les formes mais on peut
très bien moi je ne concevrais en
témoigna cantona se concevrait bon on te
remercie tu as tu as fait du bon boulot
tu nous a amenés là maintenant nous on
veut insuffler un autre un autre un
autre élève un autre discours on veut
autre chose mais c'est pour ça et on n'a
pas vraiment tous les éléments pas tous
les voir répondre parce que bien sûr que
moi j'ai pas remis en cause surtout pas
les qualités de cet entraîneur il a les
qualités techniques et humaines qui sont
formidables la preuve il a les résultats
qui sont là mais c'est savoir déjà lui
est ce qu on lui a posé la question est
ce que lui veut continuer en tout cas il
ya posé la question à la dernière fois
l'interview il avait envie de continuer
il prépare son groupe pour la saison
prochaine
le faire et puis en fait il que trois
personnes qui sont capables de de nous
aiguiller là dessus sur le choix dans la
date du départ ou de la continuité de de
youssef civis et ce sont les deux
présidents qui est une fibule
beaucoup moins exposé que la ligue 1 où
la ligue 2 le projet de la continuité je
pense que c'est le meilleur à choisir
pour pour continuer pour mercer en tout
cas on suivra avec attention les
mouvements de ce mercato estival à
versailles l'été sera sûrement un très
chaud dans la cité royale on passe
maintenant à notre page débats
[Musique]
dans cette page débats on va parler des
jeux olympiques de paris 2024
l'événement planétaire se précise dans
les yvelines tony estanguet est venu
visiter le 28 avril dernier le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
l'occasion de la tournée des sites il
est monté sur un vélo et a pu tester une
nouvelle fois la piste cet événement a
permis de lancer cette initiative pour
faire monter l'effervescence autour de
ce rendez vous on l'écouté au micro de
tv 78 c'est un symbole assez fort de
commencer la tournée décide de paris du
24 ici au vélodrome nationale vous savez
le vélo vert national c'est un peu la
fierté du sport français c'est l'un des
fleurons c'est un équipement incroyable
1 qui allie à la fois le sport de très
haut niveau mais aussi comme aujourd'hui
des moments d'initiation de pratique
ouvert à tous c'est un peu ça l'esprit
de paris 2024 on veut que les athlètes
français sont dans les meilleures
conditions on veut qu'il gagne un
maximum de médailles on a envie que les
françaises et les français les
soutiennent soit derrière eux il n'y a
rien de mieux que d'essayer un sport
pour être ensuite conquis et d'avoir
vraiment envie de soutenir ces athlètes
l'a donc aujourd'hui c'est une première
étape importante pour nous et on est
ravi d'être ici avec les plus grands
champions français en plus qu'est ce que
vous en pensez de cette venue de tony
estanguet au vélotour national de saint
quentin en yvelines aude riche qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais c'est toujours
un intervalle voir si toujours une
personnalité en plus c'est vraiment
méritants et je suis assez admiratif de
son parcours c'est ça va être
impressionnant de le rencontrer je
tirais pas de miraculés des grands
champions et de ce qu'ils incluent aussi
la valeur les principes il ya l'esprit
qui souhaitent aussi fédérer donc
j'aimerais me dire oui parfait allons-y
alors légaux il était comment tony
estanguet ce coût très abordable et
sympathique mais j'en doutais pas j'aime
c'est en tout cas le l'image qui
renvoyait moi quand j'avais pu voir en
interview dans d'autres dans d'autres
médias donc d'entrée accessible on a pu
même interviewé avant qu'il commence sa
visite du vélodrome ils avaient le choix
dans la date pour débuter cette tournée
des sites olympiques il a débuté il a
choisi de débuter cette tournée au
vélodrome nationale donc je pense qu'on
peut que s'en réjouir et il y avait donc
un engouement engouement lancy on a un
peu plus de deux ans désormais de ces jo
de paris et donc on a hâte que ça arrive
voilà c'est ça
je vois rire ça lance parfaitement les
jeux olympiques cette venue de tony
estanguet il le dit lui-même est ravie
de commencer par le vélodrome ne sait
quand elle a parlé tout à l'heure qui
est vraiment magnifique site et non mais
c'est bien plus on n'a qu'à faire à
monsieur quand même du sport français
donc là c'est quand même voilà c'est
quand même
nom mais pour qui je ça me surprend
absolument pas seven à l'image qu'ils
renvoient d'être quelqu'un d'accessible
de 2,2 c'est super c'est ça
un très beau
ça veut dire deux choses à dire
effectivement on a on a un porte drapeau
mondialement reconnu comme président du
comité d'organisation communauté
sebastian coe pour londres il ya
quelques années et puis deuxièmement
c'est la richesse des installations
existantes en france pour la réception
de jeux olympiques on a on a un certain
nombre d'enceintes justement dont on a
dont on a beaucoup parlé et avec les
choix qui sont faits de pouvoir ouvrir
au plus grand nombre avec cette
cérémonie d'ouverture autour de la scène
qui est juste une idée une idée de génie
et j'espère qu'elle va se réaliser que
ça sera vraiment dans les grandes dans
les grandes largeurs et et
grandiloquente parce que on a vraiment
on est parti pour faire d organiser des
jeux absolument mémorable à paris alors
l'après midi ces singes à mansle et qui
était à l'honneur la ville a signé ce
jeudi 28 avril un partenariat avec le
comité olympique britannique et son
président jürg robertson ce qui signifie
que la team gb viendra donc s'entraîner
ici dans la ville yvelinoise pendant le
rendez vous parisien la délégation qui
compte en général entre 350 et 400
sportifs s'entraînera au stade georges
lefèvre camp des loges 80% des
disciplines devrait pouvoir s'exercer
sur ce site on pense notamment au tennis
avec les cours déjà présents football
avec les terrains utilisés par l'équipe
du paris saint-germain ya également la
piste d'athlétisme et le stade de rugby
utilisé par l'équipe locale du mlg p les
terrains de beach volley ou encore le
hockey sur gazon la ville excellent dans
ce sport et peut compter sur des à
terrain flambant neuf pour la ville de
saint jean les c'est donc un très gros
morceau la délégation prêta ict
britannique termine régulièrement en
haut du tableau final des médailles à
tokyo la team grande bretagne avait
terminé quatrième avec 65 médailles le
maire de la commune arnaud péricard
s'est donc félicité de ce partenariat on
l'écouté
[Musique]
déjà c'est la concrétisation d'un
travail de séduction que nous avons
opéré depuis presque deux ans maintenant
pour avoir le plaisir de les accueillir
et puis c'est le début de cette aventure
olympique pour nous laisser germanois
être s'inscrire dans cette dynamique que
constitue paris 2024 voilà en étant en
ile de france on est à quelques
kilomètres de paris c'est normal aussi
de d'avoir ou de s'associer à cette
aventure collective et si en plus on
peut le faire en mettant à disposition
nos infrastructures et je suis ravi en
tout cas que les anglais aient trouvé
ici à les anglais la team djiby et
trouver ici des infrastructures dignes
de leur capacité à obtenir beaucoup de
médailles c'est l'une des plus grandes
nations sportives au monde donc on est
très fiers et très honorés de les
accueillir
j'ai posé la question c'était
intéressant on a ici une communauté
anglo saxonne très forte donc je posais
la question de savoir si ça avait été un
élément important en fait non pas du
tout je crois que ce qui fait la
différence ce sont deux choses c'est la
qualité des infrastructures sportives ça
c'est là le premier élément et je crois
que le deuxième c'est la dimension
peut-être humaine que nous avons mis et
la qualité de l'accueil que nous avons
apportées voilà on les voulait on leur a
dit qu on les aimait et qu'on avait très
envie de les avoir ici et je crois que
de se sentir accueilli de se sentir un
peu comme dans une famille ici c'est ce
qui va faire la différence
quasiment tout quelques disciplines en
raison des infrastructures auront lieu à
reims évidemment la voile n'aura pas
lieu à saint germain ça sera je pense à
marseille très très certainement et tout
le reste aura lieu ici mais au delà de
la pratique de ces disciplines sportives
c'est également tout un environnement et
tout un ensemble et c'est ça qui fait la
différence ce sont les golfs ce sont la
forêt c'est la possibilité d'aller se
baigner d'aller au cinéma d'être un
petit peu loin du tumulte parisien de
pouvoir profiter de paris si vous pouvez
si vous avez envie de vous détendre à
paris à quelques minutes en rer et puis
de revenir ici sur sa base arrière loin
à l'oxygène alors qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la venue d'un team
grande-bretagne assange amand les eauxde
riches moi j'ai dit yes j'ai dit walton
bay comme la team djiby j'emmène dire
balesi vince & the place to be et bien
sûr comme le dit le maire de saint
germain en laye à nos pays car il faut
savoir les accueillir à avoir
effectivement du matériel de haute
qualité et comme on dit si bien c'est il
faut avoir un bel entraînement il faut
comme dirait un joueur je les cite
effectivement une des clés du succès
c'est la confiance en soi et une
desquels la confiance en soi et la
préparation c'est un joueur de tennis
sportif arthur h et j'ai trouvé ça
complètement méritant parce que quand on
a du matériel et on a des joueurs des
prochains champions il faut les soutenir
et saint-germain-en-laye c'est encore un
côté de chez moi donc je suis très
content je me serais ce que je faisais
les aides pour les apercevoir
ça jamais en laye à des pubs anglais où
je pouvais pas voir terre ferme et mon
anglais donc j'aime beaucoup les anglais
et viennent à partir de cet été
apparemment
genre vous êtes a trouvé cette équipe d
années
d activité oui oui les gens vous par
contre les anglais fulham et les zincs
je suis jolie voix j'aime bien que d'y
perdre notamment donc là on les entraîne
pour qu'ils perdent ensuite voilà non
mais c'est très bien c'est très bien
parce que c'est quand plaisanterie mise
à part c'est une grande nation
sur le plan des jeux olympiques et leur
venue à saint germain c'est quand même
une reconnaissance 65 médailles à tokyo
voilà car on sait qu'avec une
reconnaissance pour la ville et pour ses
installations parce que ce genre d
équipe elle veut ce qui se fait de
meilleur cours pour amener ses athlètes
à plusieurs au meilleur résultat donc
c'est très très très bien que ça se
passe à une fois de plus sur une commune
des yvelines et saint germain pour la
cité on connaît la richesse des riches
et des installations yvelinoise là en
multi sports hélas que j'y vois avec
effectivement un je dirais une affection
limité pour les anglais ou les anglais
ont tiré les premiers ils ont ils ont en
gros ils ont déjà préempté peut-être ce
qui sera une des uns des meilleurs camp
de base gio en france m donc là pour le
coup et comme là ils sont ils sont
relativement fort à ça il ya dans la
prévision et l'organisation je pense que
c'est une très bonne chose pour les
yvelines c'est moins bon pour les autres
les autres délégations internationales
parce qu'en fait ils ont je pense qu'ils
font un très bon choix évidemment autour
de ce plateau on va le confirmer mais
ils font un très bon choix il ya tout ce
qu'il faut en terme d'installations pour
vraiment préparé et bien s'y préparer
l'ensemble des disciplines sportives
j'ai pu parler un petit peu avec hugh
robertson l'un des responsables de cette
team jbe il m'a dit qu'il y avait le
site certes mais il ya également la
forêt était juste à côté twitter
proximité avec paris avec notamment le
tramway qui va arriver en cinq minutes
on sera dans le sens de
saint-germain-en-laye depuis camp des
loges il ya également le rer a pour
aller sur sur paris et il ya en plus une
piscine olympique il est présente
il avait cité dans le reportage il y
avait le goal ici alors le golf ça
serait plus pour se détendre apparemment
d'après ce qui a préparé l'épreuve
l'épreuve aussi ils sont pas si loin du
golf national aussi derrière et puis il
ya des il ya des stades le stade de la
mêlée gp que vous avez cités je crois
qu'il ya encore une piste de vélo autour
donc si besoin aussi besoin était mais
non c'est ils vont être tranquille à
l'aise et ils auront tous pour performer
très rapidement passe à la prochaine
thématique pas rapidement ses quelques
uns d'entre eux nouvelle de plus pour le
département des yvelines on va être au
coeur de ces de cevio et ça on peut que
s'en réjouir en plus d'autres épreuves à
venir en plus de 7 ce camp de base à
saint germain en laye il faut citer
aussi qu'à 14 collectivités binoche qui
sont aire de jeu on pourrait avoir les
épreuves de cyclisme sur route en tout
cas c'est quasiment confirmé qu'ils
passeraient à saint quentin en yvelines
au pied du vélodrome et on en attente de
la confirmation peut-être le marathon
pour tout ce qui passerait par la ville
de versailles donc encore des épreuves
en plus on a en a pas fini avec les
hymnes vont être comblés dans les
yvelines a en tout cas déjà être
d'autres jeux olympiques de 2024 ils
seront programmés du 26 juillet au 11
août une fois n'est pas coutume on a
parlé de culturisme au bodybuilding en
anglais en france ils sont plusieurs
milliers à pratiquer ce sport dans les
yvelines julien un vernis zee est un
passionné il participe à des concours
amateurs espèrent un jour obtenir sa
carte professionnelle pour atteindre cet
objectif l'athlète d'un mètre 77 77 pour
cent kilos doit convaincre sur scène un
jury lors de ces rendez vous ici dans sa
catégorie les observateurs évaluent le
buste des participants selon plusieurs
critères et nous on est plus en fait
homme de plage donc c'est à dire on va
avoir des positions dites naturelles
donc évident y en a quand même un
travail spécifique de la contraction on
essaie d'être le plus relâchée possible
et effectivement d'avoir une prestance
d'une aisance sur scène ce qui est plus
important d'avoir ce qu'on appelle le
pudding
et en fait on est jugé sur sa sur la
comédie sur la symétrie sur la masse
musculaire mais également sur ce qu'on
va dégager sur scène c'est un peu comme
un j'ai envie de faire un concours de
miss france mais pour des mecs musclés
quoi alors pour faire découvrir sa
passion au plus grand nombre julien
sorti un film sur son parcours dans le
milieu du bodybuilding un documentaire
de 25 minutes projeté pour la première
fois à paris au mois de mars sur
l'objectif combattre les clichés sur
cette discipline - aujourd'hui à mon
petit niveau à ma petite échelle
j'essaye de combattre ça justement faire
comprendre qu'on n'est pas tous des tout
dans le dans les bras et dans le cerveau
le but c'est vraiment de faire
comprendre que voilà on peut faire cette
discipline
mais quelqu'un de normal aussi d'avoir
un business à côté de faire sa vie et
d'être quelqu'un d'intelligent parce que
voilà il faut savoir que malgré tout il
faut quand même être cadré et
intelligent pour faire ce sport là bas
alors julien un vernis z'y va maintenant
continuer à sculpter son corps sur cette
année à 2022 avant de reprendre la
compétition au premier semestre 2023
avec toujours cet objectif en tête
passer professionnel la question sur
cette thématique julien peut-il briser
les clichés sur le bodybuilding oui ou
non voter
avec son initiative
sont son film de 25 minutes
c'est son plus grand désir 11 ans
seulement oui nous bonjour je vous donne
la parole
oui alors c'est vrai que
c'est très très très dur comme le sport
c'est très très dur
fraîchement pour arriver à
ce résultat il sait des heures des
heures et des heures à lever de la fonte
c'est très dur mais bon comme tout sport
de de bon niveau on va dire après pour
arriver à changer les idées
ça va être très compliqué parce que le
problème c'est qu'à ce sport là et ça
existe malheureusement c'est que il ya
le dopage la park hôtel alors pour
parler à fond les produits illicites qui
font caniveau si on veut performer et si
on veut aller plus haut mais
malheureusement malheureusement pour
parler vulgairement dans le langage il
faut qu'il charge et pour changer les
idées là-dessus ça va être très
compliqué pour lui parce que
malheureusement pour lui ça existe et ça
peut pas le nier on a énormément c'est
un sport qui évoquaient d'autres parlent
beaucoup on a énormément de grands
champions qui malheureusement sont
souvent des cds par ben c arrêt
cardiaque
blier lié à malheureusement à ces
produits illicites qui se met pour
prendre de la masse musculaire pour pour
sécher pour il ya des produits qui sont
faits pour ça mais qui sont les lego
mais y en a d'autres qui ne le sont pas
sauf que ça ça va plus vite et à
certains niveaux pour changer ces idées
là je sais qu'il a ça dans la tête
j'ai mon cousin qui a été championne de
france de cette discipline donc il n'a
jamais voulu aller plus haut parce que
justement il est obligé de passer un cap
qui ne voulaient pas franchir et donc il
est resté comme ça ils étaient comme lui
à peu près c'était voilà c'était des
mecs qui se sont entraînés à la force
mais il souhaite très dur pour lui très
compliqué de changer l'image que
certains et que beaucoup en sur ce sport
là au dress je pense que c'est tout à
son honneur de pouvoir un petit peu
brisé un petit peu ce clivage sur le
bodybuilding alors il ya trois sujets le
premier je pense qu'il faut pas arrêter
quelqu'un qui a un rêve en tête et qui a
envie de faire changer les choses le
deuxième sujet je te rejoins
complètement sur la santé peut-être que
c'est là où alors on peut travailler
sujet est sûre sur le ce que j'ai mis
dans son dans son expérience auprès de
julien c qui en fait il a traversé
toutes les étapes classiques et se dire
moment donné c'est tellement clivant
comment est ce que je peux faire
transformer cette discipline et la
rendre plus accessible avec une autre
méthode à une autre moyen de communiquer
de le transférer donc à tout à son
honneur
pierre je suis tout appris il n'aurait
tout appris et c'est un autre exemple
s'il en fallait je reviens pas sur ce
que ce qu'audrey gens ont dit c'est un
autre exemple s'il en fallait de
l'utilisation des moyens modernes de
communication comme les réseaux sociaux
on en a parlé pour le club de foot il ya
quelques il ya quelques semaines sur ce
plateau de ceux qui utilisent les
réseaux sociaux pour justement amener
plus de monde à s'intéresser à leur
discipline à changer les choses
effectivement ça va être ça va être
compliqué parce qu'il ya un certain
nombre de clichés qui ont la peau dure
mais en tout cas on peut on peut saluer
le saluer l'initiative l'ags auriez vous
avez 20 secondes elles n'ont pas tous
dans les muscles puisqu'on peut citer un
exemple très connus arnold
schwarzenegger qui a été mister univers
c'est une figure du socialisme et qui
est en plus devenu après il affine
politique gouverneur de californie 72 il
a été mentionné 3,72 ninon seuls 12 des
clichés tout est calé sur le culturisme
genre je vous lis je vois ça alors c'est
déjà à la fin de cette émission on va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation de cristiano ronaldo le
footballeur je ne sais pas pourquoi je
suis tout le temps sifflée c'est parce
que je suis beau riche et bon et que je
fais à des envieux je n'ai pas d'autre
explication je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]